[Musik]
phoenix persönlich mein heutiger gast
ist gregor gysi
die meisten wissen dass sie viele jahre
partei und fraktionsvorsitzender der
linken beziehungsweise der pds waren
schon weniger bekannt ist dass sie
derzeit präsident der europäischen
linken sind herzlich willkommen bei
phoenix persönlich guten tag die partie
der letzte satz ihrer autobiografie hat
mir sehr gut gefallen ich bin wild
entschlossen das alter zu genießen was
heißt das dann in ihrem fall dass ich
leider noch nicht weiß weil es beginnt
ich bin ja erst 70 aber wenn bin ich
wirklich wild entschlossen ich sagte ihm
halten wenn man die könnte ich einfach
so alt werden wissen sie der merken sie
der fuß tut weh oder das ohr hört nicht
mehr richtig
man muss wirklich beschließen es zu
genießen und dazu werden zwei
erkenntnisse erstens man ist gar nicht
verpflichtet alles zu vererben wenn man
einen wunschtraum hatte den man sich
leisten kann dann soll man sich denn
auch erfüllen und wenn die tochter der
da so meine viertel minute schief gucken
halt durch und das zweite ist man darf
nicht die ganze zeit über krankheiten
reden davon wird man nicht gesund und
wenn man das einhält dann kann man das
alter auch genießen
jetzt sind sie ja aktiv wie immer nach
wie vor bundestagsabgeordneter und die
funktion des präsidenten der
europäischen linken habe ich schon
angesprochen
dabei hätten sie ja nun durchaus gründe
etwas kürzer zu treten sie hatten
immerhin dreimal einen herzinfakt ja das
stimmt also meine kinder haben zu mir
gesagt dass ich nicht mehr sondern
weniger zeit habe aber ich höre an dazu
und das liegt daran dass ich
verantwortung abgegeben habe wissen sie
den notfällen warf auf mich immer pallas
aber jetzt interessiert mich auch der
alltag ich möchte sie wissen was sie da
so treiben und wie das alles läuft und
das ist wichtig in der politik müssen
die meisten aus der ersten reihe noch
lernen dass man auch aufhören können
muss leben sie denn rücksicht auf ihre
gesundheit begrenzt sich neben tabletten
und ich mache etwas mehr sport als sonst
ich fahre gerne fahrrad natürlich ein
bisschen faul wie ich bin e bikes gibt
ich schwimme gerne ich wandere
inzwischen gerne und im winter
auch skilauf das finde ich sehr gesund
noch ein satz von ihnen ist mir
aufgefallen
in meinem alter ändert man sich nicht
mehr viel man bleibt er wie man ist wie
sind sie denn das weiß ich nicht das
kriege ich auch nicht kurz
zusammengefasst aber es gibt so ein paar
elemente die einem auffallen die man
sich nicht mehr abgewöhnen kann ich bin
in gewisser hinsicht zum beispiel ein
pingel
das ging den gerichten in der ddr auf
die nerven weil ich die gesetze immer
genau das und sie dann auch genau dass
man nicht ihre stärke auszudrücken was
sie eigentlich wollten
und das ist auch so geblieben zum
beispiel erzählt mir jetzt die
mitglieder meiner fraktion dass ich
früher jeden antrag gelesen habe und
immer handwerklich korrigiert habe und
das passiert jetzt nicht mehr auf
kommasetzung dann natürlich das ist
deswegen sage so leicht penetrant und
film ich bin ich da selbst wenn ich
wissen sie auf meinem handy ich nutze
sie richtig quatsche ja weil ich zu faul
bin zum schreiben aber ich korrigiere
das immer durch einschließlich konnte
sind sie auch deswegen noch politisch
aktiv und so engagiert weil ihr
lebenswerk die linke bedroht ist also
auf jeden fall bin ich politisch einfach
hoch interessiert ich will ja wissen was
in dieser welt vorgeht und ich glaube
dass ein problem mit dem was jetzt
wirklich zu tun haben und zwar von den
usa bis zu deutschland darin besteht
dass viele menschen nicht mehr verstehen
was da eigentlich passiert
ich will man nur eine frage welche
interessen verfolgen in syrien
eigentlich assad putin der iran die
türkei es sah und hier arabien der
islamische staat ihre bälle die rebellen
b die rebellen c wer soll denn das noch
verstehen können und ich sage jetzt mal
ein fehler von uns beiden ich mein ich
uns als person sondern von den medien
und der politik wir erklären zu wenig
auf und das hat folgen
wir können uns ja bemühen in dieser
sendung aufklärerisch tätig zu sein
deswegen kläre ich mal auf warum ich
glaube dass die linke durchaus in gefahr
ist erstens verlust der sonderstellung
und vieler wähler im osten an die afg
und zweitens führungsstreit innerhalb
der linken um die rolle von aus
aufstehen da würde ich gerne mal damit
anfangen
sahra wagenknecht und oskar lafontaine
haben zu einer linken sammlungsbewegung
aufstehen aufgerufen was halten sie denn
davon
naja ich bin ja bisher nicht beigetreten
das haben die beiden sie dann gefragt ob
sie mitmachen wollen
nein aber da kann man sich ja freiwillig
rein melden wenn man will
das ist schon meine erste kritik wir
haben aktive gewerkschafter die hat noch
ganz andere leute bringen können wenn
sie mich gefragt hätten ich habe noch
einen anderen zugang zu
sozialdemokratinnen und sozialdemokraten
so zu beschimpfen oder zu künstlerinnen
und künstlern oder zu wissenschaftler
sie haben es nur zu zweit gemacht das
ist mir ein bisschen eng aber in
wirklichkeit ja wenn man kurz
übersetzten also der vorwurf lautet dass
eine ego nummer von den beiden das ist
jetzt ihre interpretation ich lasse ist
bei dem was ich geschildert habe wobei
sie das jetzt auch merken also sie ich
glaube dass sie jetzt weiter werden
wollen aber das zweite ist eine gefahr
die ich sehe für die europäische den
grund für die deutsche linke und da
haben sie recht
und die gefahr besteht im folgenden bei
vielen meinungsverschiedenheiten kann
man immer kompromisse finden das ist gar
nicht so schwer das macht einen sogar
breiter aber es gibt jetzt eine zentrale
meinungsunterschied und der besteht und
folgen dann müssen wir den meisten
herausforderungen vor denen wir stehen
vornehmlich national begegnen oder
vornehmlich internationalistisch
begegnen und das es in der europäischen
linken umstritten und in der deutschen
auch und da haben sie recht da sehe ich
auch nicht den kompromiss wie kriege ich
zwischen einer nationalen in einer
internationalistischen am ort den
kompromiss das macht mir ernsthaft
sorgen
also ich würde das jetzt gern noch ein
bisschen erläutern weil ja vielleicht
nicht jeder so in diesen verästelungen
drin sind also vereinfacht ausgedrückt
oskar lafontaine und sahra wagenknecht
sagen wir müssen der afg wähler wieder
abspenstig machen indem wir die
flüchtlingspolitik von angela merkel
kritisieren weil wir brauchen nationale
lösungen nur der nationalstaat kann den
sozialstaat garantieren und sie sagen
frei ausgedrückt wir brauchen
europäische lösungen
ich das richtig zusammengehört haben sie
richtig hinter plötzlich es kommen noch
zwei punkte hinzu dass sie beide raus
wollen aus dem euro ich wollte nicht
rein aber finde es jetzt völlig falsch
rauszugehen und dass sie auch die
rückübertragung von befugnissen der eu
auf den nationalstaat volt und dieselben
themen habe ich alle in der europäischen
linken also es ist nicht nur auf
deutschland spezialisiert und das ist da
ist es auch wirklich schwer einen
kompromiss zu gewinnen
ich sage immer was zu den flüchtlingen
ich hab's organisch dagegen fdp und csu
sollen sich doch über obergrenzen
streiten unsere aufgabe ist eine andere
die aufgabe der linken ist zu sagen das
sind die ursachen der flucht bewegung
und das sind die schritte die man sogar
schnell gehen kann um diese ursachen zu
beseitigen
das ist die aufgabe der linken denn die
konzerne haben einst angerichtet die
soziale frage was schon immer auch eine
internationale war vorwiegend eine
nationale und die haben durch handy und
internet folgte sorgt das ist eine
menschheitsfrage geworden ist und von
der linken erwarte ich dass sie darauf
eine antwort sucht und findet
jetzt haben sie ja gerade dass er
inhaltlich trennende zwischen ihnen
wagenknecht und lafontaine geschildert
gleichzeitig waren sie ja immer einer
derjenigen der ist beklagt hat dass die
linke so zersplittert ist also der
grundgedanke zu sagen wir machen eine
linke sammlungsbewegung wo man
vielleicht dann auch mal eine
inhaltliche auseinandersetzung
beiseiteschieben müsste der müsste ihnen
doch eigentlich durchaus gelegen ist ja
auch völlig richtig
wir haben aber schon solche
gesprächskreise es ist immer die frage
waren es die zeit reif
wir hatten ja eine mehrheit von spd
linken und grünen in der letzten
legislaturperiode und sie wurde nicht
genutzt
ich glaube dass die spd jetzt weiter ist
jetzt muss man es inhaltlich allerdings
vorbereiten die spd hat wie ich finde
den großen fehler begangen wieder in die
große koalition zu gehen
das wird dir nicht bekommen sie wird
langsam anfangen um ihre existenz
kämpfen zu müssen wenn das so weitergeht
sie hätte sich jetzt als alternative zur
union aufbauen
das war die historische aufgabe das hat
sie nicht gemacht trotzdem bleibe ich
heinz weg optimist und sage wir beide
werden noch erleben dass sie vielleicht
zu dritt im bund regieren aber das geht
nur wenn sie wirklich eine alternative
politik machen und damit auch das
die fdp zu wählen grundlegend andere
bleiben noch mal bei der
sammlungsbewegung viel streit entzündet
sich ja an den handelnden figuren also
vor allem an wagen nicht und und
lafontaine
nehmen sie patenten beiden denn ab dass
es ihnen darum geht die linke zu einen
oder gehören sie zu denen die sagen nach
die kämpfen er macht und einfluss ich
kann ihnen nur sagen wie es in europa
empfunden wird in europa wird die
sammlung für bei den linken in europa
empfunden als etwas wo es darum geht
eine einschränkung der
flüchtlingspolitik und andere dinge
durchzusetzen das heißt über die
bewegung auf die linke druck auszuüben
dass sie sich in ihrem fuß und ändert
aber mir geht es dabei um die person
eine sammlungsbewegung an sicherheit ich
für richtig nur wenn ich das mal ganz
nebenbei sagen darf sahra wagenknecht
und oskar lafontaine wandel nicht die
vorkämpfer für ein zusammengehen mit spd
und grünen
da gab es ganz andere in meiner partei
die er dafür war aber umso besser wenn
sie jetzt die erkenntnis gewonnen
nein das stört mich alles nicht mir geht
es wirklich um die inhaltlichen fragen
und wie wir das gut vorbereiten so
vorbereiten dass wirklich mal ein
richtiger regierungswechsel in berlin
stattfinden kann
packen wir jetzt mal diese
sammlungsbewegung ab und schauen uns mal
die von mir geschilderten zweite
bedrohung der linken an nämlich der
verlust von wählern an die afd
wir haben dazu eine grafik von infratest
dimap das ist die sonntagsfrage alle
bezogen auf die östlichen bundesländer
wenn am nächsten sonntag bundestagswahl
wäre dann würde in den östlichen
bundesländern das so aussehen stärkste
partei wäre mit 27 prozent die afg
zweitstärkste die cdu mit 23 an dritter
stelle die linke mit 18 prozent die spd
erst auf position mit 15 sehen doch dass
ich mir jetzt zu recht auch sorgen um
die spd mache ja aber das ist jetzt
nicht unser hauptthema sind und ich
würde von ihnen gerne wissen wie es die
afg schaffen konnte an der linken vorbei
zu ziehen
die ard geht inzwischen auch im osten
als protestpartei das waren wir mal
aber wenn du in der regierung im
berliner landtag bist also nicht in der
bundespolitik aber in der berliner
landespolitik wenn du in der regierung
bis in brandenburg wenn du den
ministerpräsidenten von thüringen stellt
kannst du dich hier hundertmal prozessen
partei nennen die leute glauben ist ihr
nicht mal das zweite ist durch die
vereinigung mit der bsg sind nicht mehr
die ostdeutsche partei sondern eine
bundesweite linke partei geworden die
jetzt auch ernsthaft zb kämpft in
verschiedenen landtagen in den alten
bundesländern einzuziehen und wir sitzen
da ja zum teil auch drin
es hat auch unseren charakter bella darf
man nicht vergessen trotzdem bleiben wir
natürlich ein sprachrohr aber es kommt
folgendes hinzu ich würde ihnen erklären
warum die afd
erstens in ganz deutschland ein problem
ist oder vielleicht besser erklären
warum sie noch stärker gewinnt im osten
das sind fünf punkte ich mache es so
kurz wie möglich die außer deutschen
fühlen sich als verlierer der geschichte
sie hatten die sowjetische
besatzungsmacht mit den westlichen war
es einfacher das zweite ist die
ostdeutschen kaum aus der ddr die eine
geschlossene gesellschaft war
du hattest in chemnitz und dresden keine
möglichkeit menschen muslimischen
glaubens kennen zu lernen oder gar zu
lernen mit ihnen zu leben und umzugehen
ein bisschen anders war es in leipzig
und ostberlin
da gab es solche menschen ist
hochinteressant deshalb ist das afd
ergebnis in leipzig und ostberlin aus
schlechter als in den anderen städten
ostdeutschlands das hängt mit der ddr
geschichte zusammen das dritte ist was
verheerend war das bei der herstellung
der deutschen einheit sieg einer
gleichberechtigten deutschen wohnen
sondern sollte zweiter klasse ich meine
wir haben märz 28 jahre 1
es gibt immer noch niedrigere renten im
osten immer noch niedrigere löhne sogar
bei längerer arbeitszeit bei gleicher
arbeit das ist einfach nicht mehr zu
vertreten
und dann geht es nicht nur um das
materielle das demütig auch der vierte
grund ist dass es eine
massenarbeitslosigkeit 90 91 92 93 gab
wie sie der besten glücklicherweise
nicht kennenlernen musste und deshalb
sind die ängste doppelt so groß und
jetzt sagen sich die leute erst hat sie
einer die arbeitsplätze genommen jetzt
nehmen muss die flüchtlinge die
arbeitsplätze
zwar nicht aber so sieht es in den
köpfen aus und das fünfte was mich auch
sehr ärgert ist wenn sie sich den
rechtsextremismus angucken npd usw
die anführer kommen immer aus dem westen
oder das fußvolk aus dem osten also das
ärgert mich noch in besonderer weise mit
all dem haben wir es zu tun und wenn man
das erkennt dann kann man auch dagegen
vorgehen und jetzt und da haben sie
recht gehabt wo hin gibt es die einen
die sagen zum beispiel wie seehofer und
söder wir müssen die afg entgegenkommen
wenn wir das machen
ziehen wir die wählerinnen und wähler ab
zu uns ich glaube das ist das nicht
aufgeht damit legitimiert du nur die
wahl der ft ich sage immer ich will auch
wählerinnen und wähler zurückgewinnen
aber indem ich sie vom gegenteil
überzeugen
sonst habe ich keine chance treffen sie
manchmal auf wähler die ihnen sagen
früher habe ich links gewählt wie linke
gewählt jetzt will ich das nicht aber
ich treffe ein fehler die mir sagen dass
er afd wählen ob sie früher links
gewählt haben vielleicht weiß ich nicht
sagen sie nicht und dann sagen sie mir
was mich am meisten nachdenklich macht
ihn sind eigentlich die wahlen egal
die demokratie ist illegal und sie
wählen die weil sie merken darüber
ärgern sich alle anderen am meisten
und weil sie sich über alle anderen
merken man vergisst nämlich das
politische establishment verliert seine
anerkennung sehr ein grund weshalb trump
gewählt worden ist und unsere regierung
nimmt das nicht zur kenntnis die machen
einfach weiter so ist denn an dem
argument was dran dass sich die eliten
die politik die medien zu weit von der
bevölkerung entfernt oder ist was dran
wir sprechen zum beispiel eine falsche
sprache wir übersetzen doch nicht wir
reden von der veräußerungserlös gewinn
steuer dann fangen wir hier in den
sendungen dann bitte damit an
ich finde ein kleiner vorteil von mir
bestand immer daran dass ich versucht
habe die sprache wie ich es nenne zu
übersetzen mit beispiel die dinge zu
erläutern aber das ist nicht üblich in
der politik das stimmt und deshalb sage
ich immer die jetzige große koalition
beweist dass sie nicht begriffen haben
was in den usa passiert ist denn wenn
wir jetzt mal drei jahre weiter denken
dann haben wir wieder bundestagswahlen
dann wird der frust über die politischen
eliten noch größer sein
und das hat folgen selbst für uns selbst
wenn wir sagen wir sind besser halten
wir sind ja auch besser aber es nutzt es
sei noch nicht
mit der erwähnung von trump haben sie
das fenster ja schon geöffnet dass er
stark des rechtspopulismus ist ja
mitnichten ein rein deutsches phänomen
sowieso europaweit trump ein weltweites
phänomen jetzt frage ich mal den
präsidenten der europäischen linken
woran liegt das denn das von schweden
über dänemark frankreich österreich
überall derselbe trend herrscht das
liegt einmal an der schwäche der linken
sie dürfen nicht vergessen die linke
hatte im allgemeinen sind die chance im
staatssozialismus zu beweisen dass sie
eine bessere alternative zum
kapitalismus aufbauen kann
da hat sie versagt das ist hier nicht
gelungen das liegt zum anderen daran
dass man linken auch leicht misstraut
man sagt diesen sehr demokratischen
opposition aber wenn sie mal die macht
haben können sie dann aufhören
das dritte ist dass wir ja auch noch gar
keine geschlossenen antworten auf die
herausforderungen der gesellschaft haben
also es gibt gründe dafür dass die linke
schwächelt auf der anderen seite sind
die umstände was ich vorhin gesagt habe
zu kompliziert zu unübersichtlich
geworden die leute können nicht folgen
und da kommt der rechtspopulismus und
bietet an wir drehen einfach die
geschichte um 90 jahre zurück kehren
wieder zum alten nationalstaats zurück
und alles ist gelöst angeht und syrien
nichts ander geht uns das nichts an
das ist natürlich falsch das geht
überhaupt gar nicht mehr
aber es ist verführerisch und deshalb
findet jetzt so eine besinnung auf den
alten nationalstaat stadt und das ist
meistens rechts wissen ich habe einmal
folgendes gesagt natürlich muss ein
linker an der seite der armen in
deutschland stehen aber das reicht nicht
dann ist er noch nicht links ging es
erst wenn einer seite alarm steht
natürlich auch was ganz klar gegen die
armut in seinem land macht aber wenn ich
das ausland negiere wenn ich national an
die dinge herangehen und das erlebe ich
eben bei linken und bei anderen erst
recht in unseren europäischen
gesellschaften dann ist das die tiefere
ursache dass dafür dass der
rechtspopulismus so zu einem deshalb
haben wir jetzt wirklich viel zu tun
letztes jahr ist europawahl
da müssen sie als präsident der
europäischen linken dafür
sorgen dass die linke ein griffiges
programm hat um zb den rechtspopulismus
klein zu halten
wie sieht denn das aus wir haben jetzt
schon den ersten entwurf beschlossen in
der europäischen linken er wird jetzt
kann man auch änderungsanträge stellen
und dann über arbeiten über das nochmal
und ende januar werden wir das programm
vorstellen wir müssen als linke
begreifen wir müssen das gegenüber zum
rechtspopulismus und rechtsextremismus
sein
viel eher als alle anderen das müssen
wir wahrnehmen und wir müssen auch das
gegenüber zum neoliberalismus sein
dieser neoliberalismus wissen sie wo man
gesagt hat wir müssen renten sinken
löhne senken um alles verkaufen zu
können
wir ordnen alles dem
wirtschaftsinteressen unter das hat
verheerende folgen und nichts war nicht
nur für die einzelnen einzelnen dass
auch wir haben in deutschland innerhalb
der eu den größten niedriglohnsektor der
ist größer als der in griechenland wie
soll ich das jetzt mann erklärt das ist
ja geradezu abenteuerlich so und das
alles muss muss die linke wirklich
aufgreifen angreifen und zu sagen hier
liegen die antworten ist es hat mir eine
sache gefallen der vorsitzende der afd
ist beim sommerinterview ausnahmsweise
nicht nur nach flüchtlingen gefragt
worden
sonst könnte ja keinen der front nach
rente und gesundheit gefährden und
handlung von tuten und blasen keine
ahnung ich finde die medien müssten die
fdp auch mal auf andere themen
ansprechen damit viele merken dass die
da gar kein konzept haben sondern sie
haben nur ein satz der heißen
flüchtlinge sind zu viel und wenn wir
die lose sind angeblich alle probleme
gelöst was natürlich großer quatsch ist
in der politik geht es im wesentlichen
um werte und wertvorstellungen für die
man kämpft und da ist mir bei ihnen
einsatz aufgefallen der mich erstaunt
hat der heißt nämlich ich fürchte eine
gottlose gesellschaft wie das wo doch
religion opium fürs volk ist das ist
übrigens ein klassisches falsches bestes
zitat von karl marx der hat nie gesagt
religion ist opium für das volk sein hat
gesagt religion als opium des volkes ein
großer unterschied das heißt er meinte
man sucht sich die religion in der
hoffnung auf ein besseres leben jenseits
der erde etc
und nicht dass es optimiert wird ja ich
kann nicht sagen ich bin nicht gläubig
ich glaube nicht an gott aber ich
fürchte eine gottlose gesellschaft wenn
in unserer zeit wäre sie moral frei
warum kann man werte und moral nicht
anders begründen humanistisch durch karl
man kann man das problem ist es gibt im
augenblick keine kraft die das allgemein
verbindlich hinkriegt
ich bin mal ein beispiel nennen also wir
hätten ja kein weihnachten werden kein
ostern viele ja alles weg das sind ja
alles christlich begründete feiertage
warum wird weihnachten doppelt so viel
gespendet wie sonst
jeder hat ein bisschen schlechtes
gewissen hast ja nicht nach den werten
gelebt und dann fehlt ihr das wieder ein
dass du das ja solltest spende ich doch
mal was wir in die objekte in der welt
etc
es ist für mich immer hochinteressant
das zu beobachten und die linke zb war
früher auch in der lage allgemein
verbindlich moral norm zu formulieren es
sind wir heute zu schwach
die bürgerlichen kräfte können sie auch
nicht der kapitalismus gibt es nicht her
und zwar aus folgendem grund wenn der
bäckermeister in der nebenstraße in
insolvenz geht geht es dem mekka
bäckermeister b in der straße weiter
besser so einfach ist das ist zwar
logisch zu erklären aber nicht besonders
moralisch und deshalb sage ich ihn
hätten wir nicht die kirchen hätten wir
gar keine allgemein verbindliche moral
in unserer gesellschaft und das blende
ich verheerend jetzt habe ich sie
richtig verstanden wenn sie sagen sie
glauben nicht an gott gibt es dann
trotzdem irgendwas an das sie glauben
sozialismus zum beispiel ich glaube
einen letztlich an die vernunft des
menschen
deshalb bin ich ein zweckoptimist ich
mache ich weiß dass der mensch auch sehr
unvernünftig sein kann aber letztlich
glaube ich daran dass man mit vernunft
dinge erreicht ich will meinem beispiel
nennen es wird was deutlich die schwäche
unserer politik sogar der demokratie
zeigt obwohl ich für sie streiten und
kämpfen
wenn du prophylaktisch tätig bist in der
politik also mal angenommen vor zehn
jahren hätten wir dem libanon geld zur
verfügung gestellt für flüchtlinge
hätten eine andere politik in bezug auf
afrika gemacht gebe es natürlich zeitung
stellen sie sich mal vor ich wäre
kanzler gewährten über mich hergefallen
hat bleibt unser ganzes geld lieber in
afrika etc
aber wir hätten jetzt viel geringere
schäden
deshalb macht es die politik nicht sie
macht es erst wenn der schaden da ist
denn wenn wir jetzt geld dahin geben
regt sich ja keiner mehr auf und das
habe ich mir überlegt was ich sage eine
kanzlerin oder ein kanzler hat die
verantwortung prophylaktisch tätig zu
werden muss dann versuchen ist der
bevölkerung zu erklären
und selbst wenn es ihm nicht gelingt und
er abgewählt wird lebt dafür besser mit
sich weil er weiß er hat schaden
verhindert jetzt haben sie den zweiten
teil meiner frage nicht beantwortet
glauben sie an den sozialismus ja ich
glaube an den demokratischen sozialismus
wobei ich sage ganz vereinfacht er muss
das übernehmen was der kapitalismus kann
und das überwinden was der kapitalismus
nicht kann der kapitalismus kann drei
dinge er kann eine effiziente wirtschaft
hervorbringt er kann eine top
wissenschaft und forschung hervorbringen
er kann was übrigens auch der
staatssozialismus konnte dabei kann auch
eine top kunst und kultur hervorbringen
die sich zwar kritisch mit ihm
auseinander satz aber bringt sie ja
hervor jetzt sage ich eben was er nicht
kann er kann keinen frieden sichern
es geht immer um ressourcen und dann
kriegen wir zu viel verdient das muss
überwunden werden er kann keine soziale
gerechtigkeit herstellen
der reichtum konzentriert sich immer in
wenigen händen und die armut verbreitet
sich das kann nicht gut gehen
er hat schwierigkeiten mit der
ökologischen nachhaltigkeit dann wenn es
ökonomisch schadet wenn das ökonomische
nutzen nicht aber wenn es ökonomisch
schadet und letztlich keiner wie auch
der staatssozialismus keinen beitrag
leisten zur emanzipation des menschen
also sage ich ich bin ein demokratischer
sozialist nötig dazu kommt für mich nie
wieder infrage
und das zweite ist ich will die seiten
am kapitalismus retten die er kann aber
die dinge überwinden die er nicht kann
das ist meine transformations-
vorstellung aber sie können das nachher
auch demokratischen kapitalismus sein
hauptsache wir erreichen dass sie
soziale gerechtigkeit ökologische
nachhaltigkeit frieden frieden frieden
keine kriege mehr und die emanzipation
des menschen
ein großer teil ihrer familie ist bzw
war jüdischen glaubens ihr vater war
jude auch in der familie ihrer mutter
sind viele jüdisch stämmige menschen
hatte jüdische glaube in ihrem
neben der rolle gespielt nein es hat
natürlich das judentum in gewisser weise
eine rolle gespielt aber nicht der
jüdische glaube mein vater war schon
nicht gläubig seine mutter war auch
nicht gläubig plus das interessierte die
nazis ja nicht das war ja für sie nicht
die frage wissen sie ich kann mich
erinnern dass ich als kind mein
besonders bösen satz zu meiner
großmutter gesagt habe die war er
jüdisch also die mutter meines vaters
und zwar sagte die mir immer in dieser
geiger ist ein jude und der ist keiner
und so unterteilt die welt danach und
hab ich mal zu ihr gesagt weißt du nie
das geht mir auf die nerven jetzt das
völlig wurscht dass ein jude ist oder
dass ich möchte interessierten ob es ein
guter geiger also ein schlechter geiger
und dann guckt dass sie mich an und
sagte ja aber diese frage hat über mein
leben entschieden was natürlich stimmt
und was ich als kind eben nicht so
realisiert hatte aber wissen sie meine
verwandtschaft habe ich ja erst
festgestellt als ich meine autobiografie
geschrieben habe bei meiner schwester
sich zum glück auskannte im unterschied
zu mir da ist ja auch adel dabei das
sind kapitalisten dabei das alles dabei
das ist ja alles höchst spannend wir
männer denken immer dass das leben so in
den berühmten 10 bis 15 minuten oder 30
minuten entsteht das ist aber ein irrtum
da muss es vorher schon so viele leben
gehen bis dein eigenes entsteht und
wodurch die geprägt bis wir denken aber
wir sind so selbstbestimmt und wenn man
dann genau nachdenkt merkt man erst wie
man durch seine sozialisation geprägt
wurde zu denken und zu fühlen handeln
diese lernt beim schreiben der
autobiografie gelernt wenn sie das jetzt
so betonen dass einem die die
familientradition so prägen hatten die
die jüdische tradition in ihrer familie
sie auch getraff naja also wenn dazu die
ironie und die selbstironie gehört dann
schon davon war mein vater durch geprägt
kann ich nur sagen und ich habe das ja
auch übernommen das macht mir auch spaß
sowohl ironisch als auch selbstironisch
zu sein wenn du selbst ironisch presta
allerdings ein höheres selbstbewusstsein
anders geht es ja gar nicht und so mache
ich das oder habe ich das ja auch
gemacht im bundestag ich habe dann immer
gesagt also nochmal ganz einfach damit
einer wie ich das auch versteht dass das
selbstironisch und dann übersetzt sich
eben die veräußerungserlöse finden
steuer
begriff etwas anfangen können und das
scheint mir auch nötig zu sein also da
gab es schon prägungen auch in israel
und so weiter und wahrscheinlich gehört
dazu auch dass ich gleichermaßen für das
existenzrecht des staates israel streite
wie ich dafür streiten dass endlich der
staat palästina gebildet werden muss die
haben das gleiche existenzrecht und wie
ich auch weiß dass eine gruppe von
menschen die kein nationalstaat haben
benachteiligt sind neben es immer den
kurdinnen und kurden
es gibt keinen staat der sich weltweit
für sie einsetzt inzwischen durch den
staat israel gibt es einen staat der
sich weltweit für jüdinnen und juden
einsetzt so dass also es grenzen gibt
bei pogromen und was man alles aus der
geschichte kennt deshalb sage ich auch
die kurdinnen und kurden brauchen einen
nationalstaat aber wieder sage ich ihnen
was sie nicht mögen das geht nur
völkerrechtlich legitime das heißt mit
zustimmung des zentralstaates der große
fehler war ja dass man die creme gegen
die zustimmung des zentralstaates
getrennt hat vorher hat die nato gegen
die zustimmung des zentralrates dem
kosovo losgelöst ja das alles
völkerrechtswidrig also müssen wir uns
noch gedanken machen wie wir da
völkerrechtlich legitime jurist lösungen
findet für solche nation und das finde
ich schon wichtig den staat israel aber
ich finde genauso wichtig dass wir
endlich einen gleichberechtigten staat
palästina sind sie angefeindet worden
wegen ihrer jüdischen vorfahren in der
bundesrepublik förderte der in der
bundesrepublik soll es so was im
einzelnen gegeben haben aber ich
registriere sowas garnicht in der ddr
also da gibt es immer streit ich fand
die ddr nicht antisemitisch aber es gab
einen ersatz dafür sie war
intellektuellen feindlich und das habe
ich zu spüren bekommen und da habe ich
wieder die bundesrepublik überschätzt
wissen sie ich wusste gar nicht dass es
abgeordnete schon 90 1 92 93 aus den
alten bundesländern in der union gab die
sich mir unterlegen fühlten darf finde
ich gar nicht gekommen ich dachte sie
fühlen sich mir alle überlegen habe ich
fehler begangen
hätte ich gewusst dass sie so denken wie
meine funktionäre aus dem
justizministerium der wdr verstehst du
dann hätte ich damit anders umgehen
können mit intellektuellen feindlichkeit
die gab es das habe ich immer als so
eine art ersatz dafür empfunden jüdinnen
und juden gab es einfach zu wenig
allerdings gab es eine sache die mich
interessiert hat damit habe ich meinen
vater völlig durcheinander aber und zwar
beim sechs tage krieg gab es eine
erklärung von jüdinnen und juden aus der
ddr weshalb sie da israel kritisieren
und den tag vorher hat einer aus dem zk
der sed alle bekannten jüdinnen und
juden angerufen und die gefragt ob es
nun zu schreiben
in großer zahl hat nicht unterschrieben
war nicht schlimm ist nichts passiert
und da habe ich meinem vater gefahren wo
er hatte er die liste
wer hat warum diese liste erarbeitet und
ihre fahrradtour hatte keine antwort
er war auch nicht dabei aber wissen sie
das interessante ist doch so eine liste
das hat mich nachdenklich gemacht werde
ich gesagt habe darauf keine antwort
bekommen bis heute nicht wenn man älter
wird dann hat religion manchmal was
trösten dass da ist noch was wenn man
stirbt wie ist das in ihrem fall tröstet
sie da irgendwas nein ich glaube das ist
auch sinnvoll ist das unser leben und
wann aufhört das würde er auch cesar
noch leben sie mal hitler werden wir nie
losgeworden ist es doch auch furchtbar
nein so leben muss auch mal enden ich
kenne immer mehr leuten die island und
irgendwann sogar den wunsch haben zu
sterben weil es hin zu beschwerlich wird
also bin ich nicht ich fühle mich ja
auch noch jung und aktiv und will ja
auch noch vieles erleben ich habe noch
bestimmte reisen vor usw
aber nein dann ist irgendwann schluss
und ich will auch im unterschied zu
anderen verbrannt werden und die asche
soll vom meinetwegen offen mehr
zerstreut werden ich hoffe dass dann
windböe bekommt und die ganze
trauergemeinde die asche ins gesicht
bekommen müssen sie wenigstens alle
lachen und dann ist so ein hype
fröhlicher abschied von mir das war
völlig persönlich heute mit gregor gysi
herzlich danken auch am 4